get 25% off a subscription to Babel by
clicking the link below
Babel is an awesome language learning
app they're one of our sponsors I use
Babel to improve my Italian and I'm
loving the results I'd recommend Babel
to anyone go check it out
okay let's get into audience questions
for the week very timely one hey David
even if the Joe Biden's conspiracy isn't
literally true as Republicans say isn't
it still extraordinarily corrupt that
Joe Biden's son hunter Biden is working
for a Ukrainian gas company and getting
paid $50,000 a month so yes I mean he
here's what you have to distinguish and
this is so I'm gonna take the question
as being a good-faith question because I
do see a lot of bad faith right-wing
actors saying the real corruption is
Biden son and then I also see some good
faith left wing actors saying wait a
second it I am reading that it is
corrupt what was going on with Joe Biden
and hunter Biden in Ukraine so here's
the deal we have a system that is a
system built on the status quo revolving
door business politics lobbying cronyism
consultancy that that's the the system
that we have and in this system you have
kingmakers in politics and lobbyists and
elected officials and campaign
consultants and all of these faux bogus
consultancy positions that are made
available to connected people not
because of their knowledge or skills but
because of their connections like that
exists and that's a thing so I'll give
you an example Paul Ryan the former
Republican Speaker of the House as I
mentioned earlier this week is now on
the board of Fox News what does Paul
Ryan really know about being on the
board of a media company well you could
say well he did deal with the FCC as a
member of Congress or this or that or
whatever the other thing but this is
just an example of what we are talking
about it is the revolving door of people
between politics and industry and all of
that sort of stuff so when you see Joe
Biden having a son hunter Biden who's
getting paid
50 grand a month to be an adviser or
whatever to this Ukrainian gas company
it is absolutely an example of the money
buys you money and connections get you
connections and money status quo that we
have it is an example of that it is not
any particularly acute instance of what
Joe Biden is being accused of which
should change the focus of the entire
story from what Donald Trump did in
withholding hundreds of millions of
dollars in aid in exchange for Ukraine
agreeing to smear Joe Biden that should
be the focus the suppression of the
whistleblowers should be the focus so
there's that angle it's also
particularly hypocritical for Trump to
be the one calling it out because Trump
is the king of these types of crony
istic corrupt instances so do I have a
problem with what it is that hunter
Biden was doing yes in the same way that
hundreds and hundreds of relatives
friends former politicians etc etc are
in these positions because that's how
our system is built it is endemic
corruption and cronyism and it needs to
be changed at the systemic level but the
specific conspiracy that is being built
around Joe Biden and hunter Biden and
Joe Biden saying uh-oh hunters in
trouble because this company is being
investigated let me get out there and
start making some threats over bank
guarantees it's not the way it went down
it's been widely debunked and it's just
not anything that the facts can defend
and that's why we need to be
particularly careful about there's an
immediate Republicans don't care about
this revolving door status quo of
lobbyists and politicians and family
members and all of this stuff they love
it okay and for them to now say oh the
real problem is that the son of a vice
president was making a bunch of money as
a consultant here and then Joe Biden
went out to save his ass they don't
really care about this as an issue and
they are only using this hypocritically
I might add to distract from the real
chaos the real story which is Trump
suppression of the whistleblower and the
demand that Donald Trump made on Ukraine
so yeah we'll talk about
in the sense that we talked about the
whole system as it works but the acute
story here is the one related to Donald
Trump's actions